NASA will shift into planet Earth
Defense mode tonight with a mission that
is part science and part science fiction
a spacecraft will complete a 10-month
flight through the solar system and
intentionally collide with a harmless
asteroid as Mark Strassman shows us it's
just a test for a potential real threat
far far into the future
[Applause]
dark back in November NASA launched
Earth's first planetary defense mission
called Dart so far everything's looking
good the first unless you include
Hollywood
in the 1998 sci-fi thriller Armageddon
our planet's in big trouble the bullseye
for a texas-sized asteroid the United
States government just asked us to save
the world Earth's only defense Bruce
Willis you're going to remote detonate
the bomb
[Applause]
[Music]
in the real Bruce
you are
sort of Lindley Johnson's job title with
NASA planetary defense officer finding
asteroids in our solar system before
they find us more than 27 thousand
near-earth asteroids seen here in blue
have been identified so far about ten
thousand of them look large enough to
cause damage if they struck Earth as it
now stands how vulnerable
is the Earth to one of these objects to
a large object there's you know
currently nothing uh to stop it which
brings us back to Dart the double
asteroid redirection test Dart is a
spacecraft that's purposely going to
crash into an asteroid planetary
scientist Nancy Chabot leads the dart
coordination team Chabot showed us
tonight's test Target a harmless double
asteroid nearly 7 million miles away the
dart spacecraft is going to come in at
15 000 miles per hour and hit it pretty
much head on here that impact could slow
this smaller asteroid's orbit by about
one percent enough to make a
hypothetical threat Miss Earth small
nudge changes its position over time so
the earth and the asteroid wouldn't be
on a future Collision Course no known
asteroid of size threatens Earth for at
least the next hundred years a good
thing no one knows whether Dart will
work
Plan B Hollywood has some ideas the two
halves are going to miss us by
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman Laurel
Maryland
well I certainly hope should we be
scurred I mean I'm a little scared
they're that graphic there first of all
I appreciate the weather report on
asteroids we're good apparently for at
least the next hundred years they say
but that that chart showing all the
near-earth asteroids just swirling
around us that's scary that is scary see
it's all fun and games till our favorite
movies become reality that's right yeah
the thing that we're done with special
effects is actually a real thing
sometimes but it worked in the movies
though right it really did it did so
it's going to work in real life well I
don't want to give away the end of
Armageddon people might be renting it no
spoilers so you know yeah